PRESIDENT OR ANY OF HIS ALLIES,
PAM?
>> WE SHALL SEE, SARA MURRAY,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GETTING
BREAKING NEWS INTO THE
SITUATION ROOM ON THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL JANUARY SIX
INVESTIGATION.
CNN'S KATELYN POLANTZ IS
WORKING THE STORY.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING, CAITLIN?
>> PAMELA, WE JUST SAW AN ORDER
FROM THE D.C. CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS, AND WHAT THIS APPEALS
COURT IN WASHINGTON IS GOING TO
BE DOING, IS THEY WILL BE
LOOKING INTO HOW MUCH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
BEING LED BY JACK SMITH AROUND
JANUARY SIX CAN GET INTO AND
DIG INTO THE RECORDS OF MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS.
SO IT'S A REALLY BIG AND
IMPORTANT LEGAL ISSUE, A LOT OF
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE LAW AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND ALSO
SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION THAT IS ONGOING.
RIGHT NOW, THIS IS COMING HERE,
PAM, BECAUSE THERE HAS BEEN A
CASE UNDER SEAL OR THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL OFFICE IS FIGHTING FOR
ACCESS TO RECORDS ON
REPRESENTATIVE SCOTT PERRY'S
PHONE.
HE'S THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
PENNSYLVANIA, A REPUBLICAN WHO
WANTED TO REPLACE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WITH ELECTION FRAUD.
THE ADVISOR WAS IN TOUCH WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE, AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO LOOK AT, AND THE
APPEALS COURT WILL LOOK AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF WHETHER
INVESTIGATORS CAN GET ACCESS TO
RECORDS OF INFORMAL LEGISLATIVE
WORK OF A MEMBER OF CONGRESS
LIKE PERRY AND ALSO WHETHER
THEY CAN GET RECORDS OF CONTACT
HE MAY HAVE HAD WITH PRIVATE
PARTIES AND MEMBERS OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, PEOPLE LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO PERRY AND
FOUR OTHER MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
PAM, THIS WILL BE ARGUED VERY
QUICKLY, FEBRUARY 23RD, SO IN
JUST ABOUT A WEEK, AND IT WILL
BE HEARD BY THREE JUDGES IN
D.C., ALL REPUBLICAN APPOINTEES,
TWO OF WHOM WERE APPOINTED TO
THE COURT BY DONALD TRUMP
HIMSELF, PAM?
>> ALL RIGHT, WE WILL BE
WATCHING THAT CLOSELY.
JOINING US NOW, THE FORMER
REPUBLICAN LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
OF GEORGIA, JEFF DUNCAN, NOW A
CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR.
ALSO WITH US, THE FORMER AT FBI
DEPUTY DIRECTOR, ANDY MCCABE.
CNN SENIOR ANALYST, LAURA
COATES AND SPECIAL
CORRESPONDENT, JAMIE GANGEL.
LAURA, FIRST TO YOU, YOUR
REACTION TO THIS NEWS THAT THIS
APPEALS COURT WILL HEAR THIS
KEY DISPUTE?
>> IT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
GIVEN THE FACT THAT NUMBER MIN
PERRY IS ONE OF FIVE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHO ASKED FOR A PARDON,
REVEALED DURING THE JANUARY SIX
HEARINGS ON THIS ISSUE.
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE AN
INSIGHT INTO THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHETHER THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, WHICH IS UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF WHERE THE DOJ WILL
BE, WHETHER THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DO THIS TO A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH.
EXPECT TO HAVE SEPARATION OF
POWERS AND CHECKS AND BALANCES
ARGUMENTS RAISED, BUT IT IS NOT
IN ANY WAY ALLEVIATE THE
CONCERN FOR TRYING TO FIND THE
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION OF JUST
HOW SIGNIFICANT WAS THE INPUT
AND THE IMPACT OF SOMEONE LIKE
CONGRESSMAN PERRY ON TRYING TO,
AS KING SPOKE ABOUT, TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT MAYBE JEFFREY CLARK
SHOULD'VE BEEN INSTALLED AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO SUPPORT THE
ELECTION DENIALISM, AND WHAT
EVIDENCE MAY OR MAY NOT BE ON
HIS PHONE OR IN CORRESPONDENTS
ON THE ISSUE.
IT IS VERY TELLING THAT THE
APPEALS COURT DID NOT SIMPLY
SAY, FORGET IT, WASH THEIR
HANDS AND DISMISS THE ACTION
BUT INSTEAD WANT TO HEAR AND
WILL LIKELY HAVE ORAL ARGUMENTS
TO PEPPER THESE VERY QUESTIONS
TO ANSWER WHY HIM, WHY NOW AND
WHAT DID HE KNOW AND WHAT DID
HE DO?
>> RIGHT AND LOOK, HE COULD
HAVE A LOT OF IMPORTANT
INFORMATION, AND THE, IN TERMS
OF THE JANUARY 6TH
INVESTIGATION.
LAURA MENTIONED THE PARDON.
--
TOLD THE COMMITTEE THAT HE
ASKED A PARDON.
I BELIEVE HE HAS DENIED THAT.
TALK TO US A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE MAJOR IMPLICATIONS OF
THIS?
>> YOU KNOW, PAM, IT'S A REALLY
FASCINATING DEVELOPMENT, AND I
SHOULD SAY THAT THIS ISSUE OF
ACCESS TO SCOTT PERRY'S PHONE
BY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL TEAM HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE MOST HOTLY
FOUGHT BATTLES IN THE OVERALL
WAR THAT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
TEAM SEEMS TO BE WAGING HERE.
REPRESENTATIVE PERRY AS BEEN
PUSHING BACK FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY HEARINGS
AND A LOT OF COURT ACTION AND
HEARINGS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC.
IT'S FASCINATING TO SEE THIS TO
COME FORWARD.
ESSENTIALLY, WHAT LAURA SAID IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
MOST OF THE REPRESENTATIVES
ARGUMENTS WILL RELY ON
BASICALLY AN INTERPRETATION OF
THE SPEECH AND THE BIG CLAUSE
WHICH PROTECTS CONGRESS AND
MEMBERS OF COMMUNICATIONS FROM
BEING EXPOSED, IF THEY WERE
LEGISLATIVE IN NATURE.
BUT, YOU HAVE A VERY COMPELLING
AND IMPORTANT CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION HAPPENING HERE.
THE FACT THAT THE DISTRICT
COURT DID NOT DISMISS THIS OUT
OF HAND TELLS YOU THAT THEY ARE
ACKNOWLEDGING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS INVESTIGATION, THE FACT
THAT IT IS CRIMINAL AND NATURE,
THIS IS DIFFERENT FROM A
CONGRESSIONAL GRAND JURY.
SO WE WILL SEE HOW THIS BOUNCES
OUT BETWEEN THE SPEECH AND
DEBATE CLAUSE AND THE
IMPERATIVE NATURE OF CONDUCTING
A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
>> JAMIE GANGEL, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> I AM THINKING ABOUT THIS
FROM THE POLITICAL CONTACTS.
IT'S NOT JUST SCOTT PERRY WHO
WAS INVOLVED, THERE WERE FIVE
MEMBERS, FIVE REPUBLICANS,
INCLUDING THE PRESENT SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, KEVIN MCCARTHY,
WHO REFUSED TO TESTIFY TO THE
JANUARY SIX COMMITTEE, THE NOW
CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, JIM JORDAN WAS ONE
OF THOSE.
THIS STARTS WITH SCOTT PERRY
AND HIS PHONE, BUT, IT'S GOING
TO BE FASCINATING TO SEE, NOT
TO GET A HEAD OF OURSELVES
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE JUDICIAL PROCESS, BUT THIS
COULD HAVE AN IMPACT
POLITICALLY ON POTENTIALLY THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AND THESE
OTHER MEMBERS.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT IS
IMPORTANT CONTEXT FOR
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPLICATIONS
HERE.
I WANT TO TURN BACK TO FULTON
COUNTY, JEFF.
YOU WERE THE FORMER LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THE
FULTON COUNTY GRAND JURY REPORT?
WE'VE ONLY SEEN A PORTION OF IT
RELEASED, BUT WHAT STANDS OUT
TO YOU FROM THE SECTIONS
RELEASED TODAY?
>> YEAH, TWO NEWSWORTHY ITEMS
IN MY OPINION, ONE IS THAT 23
JURORS GOT TOGETHER AND
UNANIMOUSLY DECIDED THAT THERE
WAS NO FRAUD, AND SO FOR ME, TO
GET 23 PEOPLE TO AGREE ON
SOMETHING, YOU CANNOT GET THEM
TO AGREE ON WHAT COLOR THIS GUY
IS.
THE SECOND IS --
IT REALLY FEELS LIKE A STEP ONE
IN THE PROCESS.
WE HAD 75 INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
INTERVIEWED.
I WAS ONE OF THEM.
IT'S A VERY INTIMIDATING SCENE.
YOU WALK INTO THE ROOM WITH NO
ATTORNEY NEXT TO, 23 JURORS AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OFFICIALS,
AND YOU GO AT IT UNTIL YOU ARE
DONE BEING ASKED QUESTIONS.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE THAT IF ONE
PERSON SAYS SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT TRUE AND WATCH A TURNAROUND
A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS
THROUGHOUT A NINE MONTH TRIAL,
THERE WAS CERTAINLY GOING TO BE
SOME FOLKS WAITING AFTER
HEARING THE NEWS ABOUT THE
PERJURY.
>> AND YET, JAMIE, A TRUMP
SPOKESPERSON REACTED, GLOATING
THAT THE EXPERTS FROM THE
REPORT DID NOT EVEN MENTION
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NAME, WHAT DO
YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> I WOULD SAY THAT HAS BEEN
FOR AN AUDIENCE OF ONE AND A
PERSON IS DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S WHAT HE WANTS IT AND TO
HEAR, BUT WE'RE A LONG WAYS
OFF.
LOOK, THERE'S A LOT WE DON'T
KNOW FROM WHAT WAS RELEASED
TODAY, BUT IT'S LIKELY WE'RE
GOING TO FIND OUT, MUCH MORE,
AND NICE TRY, BUT THERE IS MORE
TO COME.
>> RIGHT, LET'S NOT FORGET THE
PURPOSE, INITIALLY, LAURA, FOR
THE GRAND JURY IS TO LOOK INTO
WHETHER TRUMP ILLEGALLY TRIED
TO INTERVENE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE ELECTION
AND THE RESULTS.
THE GRAND JURY FOCUSES ON THIS,
FROM WHAT HAS BEEN RELEASED.
YOU KNOW, THE PERJURY PART,
RECOMMENDING THAT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SEEK APPROPRIATE
INDICTMENTS FOR POSSIBLE
PERJURY.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
LEGAL WEIGHT THAT DR. KARI?
>> REMEMBER, THIS IS A SPECIAL
GRAND JURY, UNLIKE OUR NORMAL
NOTION OF HAVING A CRIMINAL
GRAND JURY, WHOSE SOLE PURPOSE
IS TO FIND PROBABLE CAUSE TO
ALLOW A PROSECUTOR TO ISSUE AN
INDICTMENT FOR A FELONY CHARGE.
THIS RESULT WAS A REPORT THAT
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE IDEA OF
BEING ABLE TO INVESTIGATE AND
GO FORWARD WITH A PERJURY
CHARGE.
FRANKLY, AS A PROSECUTOR, YOU
WOULD MORE LIKELY WANT TO HAVE
A CHARGE OF AN ACTUAL CRIME AS
OPPOSED TO LYING ABOUT
STATEMENT SURROUNDING THE
CRIME.
PERJURY IS A VERY SERIOUS
CHARGE, DON'T GET ME WRONG, BUT
YOU WANT TO HAVE THE MEAT ON
THE BONE, SO THIS ACTUALLY IS
GIVING SOME GREATER CREDENCE
AND GRAVITAS TO WHAT FUNNY
WILLIS WILL BE LOOKING AT,
CONFIRMING AT LEAST 23 OR SO
PEOPLE WERE IN AGREEMENT THAT
SOMEBODY BASED ON THE FAILURE
OF THE CONSISTENCY OR SOMEBODY
WAS KNOWN TO BE LYING BASED ON
THE BREADTH OF EVIDENCE THAT
THEY ACTUALLY HEARD, THAT'S
VERY TELLING OF HOW SHE MIGHT
GO FORWARD, BUT IS NOT THE END
OF THE INQUIRY, BUT IT WOULD
CERTAINLY GIVE GREATER CREDENCE
TO HER PURSUIT GOING FORWARD,
AND I WILL JUST SAY THIS, ONE
OF THE THINGS SHE SET IN OPEN
COURT WAS THE IDEA OF WANTING
TO PROVIDE FAIRNESS, TARRING
AND FEATHERING IN THE PUBLIC
SQUARE, PROVIDING ALL